la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
quitte son poste pour se lancer dans la
campagne des municipales à paris
elle confie au journal le monde qu'elle
savait que la vague du tsunami approché
des médecins dépose plainte contre agnès
buzyn et edouard philippe
à leur premier ministre pour s'être
abstenu de prendre des mesures à temps
une pétition lancée pour soutenir la
démarche des médecins sera signée par
200 mille internautes en quatre jours la
saturation des hôpitaux le manque
critique de matériel et l'épuisement des
soignants éclater au grand jour les
professionnels de santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé et les plaintes se multiplient
aussi chez les syndicats et chez les
français qui ont perdu un proche ou qui
ont été touchées par le virus
en septembre une association de victimes
du coït 19 qui réunit 200 personnes
déposent plainte contre jean castex pour
sa gestion de la pandémie sur la toile
des internautes lancent plainte qu'ovide
point fr pour encourager les français à
saisir la justice en raison des mesures
jugées tardives insuffisante et
incohérentes
le gouvernement français at il su gérer
la crise de coronavirus le doute
s'installe chez les français le 30 juin
agnès buzyn est auditionné quatre mois
plus tard c'est au tour d'edouard
philippe premier ministre jusqu'à début
juillet 2020 si bête ndiaye jérôme
salomon et olivier ferrand de faire
l'objet de perquisitions à leurs
domiciles et bureaux
au total 300 28 plaintes mettant en
cause des décideurs ou des structures
publiques ont été adressées au parquet
de paris depuis le 24 mars